and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review The Princess and the
Frog when you wish upon us fighters this
is girl named Tiana and she dreams of
owning a restaurant with her daddy
her dad is like when you grow up we're
gonna own the whispering together but
then it's like oh no I'm a parent who's
married in the Disney film I am doomed
in the knee guys who the shot go before
he died he tells Tiana something baby
you put really well your heart desires
you have an idea maybe we should put mr.
Sloane Tiana sees up all her money and
she finally gets her own restaurant but
these two guys are like we have to close
you down because we found a higher
bidder
well it's 1920 so sure princess is
timing Prince Naveen shows up and he's
like Charleston Johnston I went to get
laid but let's do call the Shadow Man
pops up and he's like I'll make a deal
with you Prince Naveen okay I'm gonna
turn you into a frog
okay wait a min 20 Oh so Prince Naveen
is now a frog
you think Tiana is a princess so
interesti trailer thinking to break the
spell but then she turns into a frog
must be a fairy tale Lupo telling talks
into the bayou and then come across this
big lip trumpet playing alligator and
I'm like cookie
should be playing alligator movement a
Mercedes all new songs written by Randy
one song over and over and over again
the song that's not the least probable
or memorable nominee for a bajillion
Oscars okay it's a deadly did you know
he was my cousin we call that the exact
same same points you got a friend in me
you've got a friend in me you say I'm
your right one song over and over -
where's my friend Jillian Oscar
nominations believe me or any sing about
how they had to go find a female witch
doctor with it technically be a doctor
week so they come across a lightning bug
me rain and he's like come on let's go
see we can fight Ella making in this
forest is final amendment but instead we
come across dr. H Mardi Gras but she has
to kiss the Frog before midnight
how many magic spells always have a
curfew brothers and the he evil Shadow
Man appears and reason lightning bull
tries to stop it to save the day yeah
but the shadow man it's like anything
but no he's dead that's distracting you
dirty but the two thoughts defeat the
Shadow Man all right when they do it
after midnight oh fuck so now being in
Tianna state frogs and they hold a
funeral for the lightning bug they use a
leaf as a coffin and the alligator plays
taps and the trumpet that's the funniest
an event I've ever seen but it's okay
because Freddie's reuniting with his
girlfriend who's a star girlfriend wife
need to go got please call me back so
everyone has a moment of silence for a
little lightning bug friend okay moment
over the surprise decide to get married
just frog and Frogger they kiss each
other in Turpan
wait what you see here is he wouldn't be
married Tiana she became a princess so
he's technically kissing a princess
making them human again sir it's a fairy
tale my lawyer so - yeah than the Vito
enough their own restaurant and they're
dancing and there happens Wilkie not
happiness when they were from and while
they're all dancing and having a good
time I'm like dude remember when it but
died that was weird
this is nice because you can kill off of
me character doesn't mean you saw it in
fact the case why didn't you kill him
Rosie O'Donnell and Tarzan that Dib Duty
eight surprises in the Frog is a
wonderful film for the whole family
the on except for insects it's not a pro
lightning bug movie except my question
is the woman's are going to be a first
bump princess we should call her boxes
and her name will be Courtney Cox this
is just to eat bugs me well at least
could you hire a princess to give mucus
my nipple turns into a rabbit
hmm